The rich get richer, and the poor get poorer.
The rich getting richer and the poor getting poorer.
The poor get poorer?
People keep talking about the evil of income inequality.
This is the living room
in a sixteen million dollar penthouse apartment.
It’s true that some rich people have gotten absurdly rich.
But the other claim that they got rich
while poor people got poorer is just a myth.
As we've increased the number of billionaires
around the world,
extreme poverty has actually shrunk down.
Former investment banker Carol Roth points out
that anyone who pays attention knows that
as the rich got richer, most poor people got richer too.
Worldwide, more than a billion
people rose out of poverty.
Yes, the rich got even richer, but why is that a problem?
Consider poor me and rich me.
Over the past 40 years,
we rich Americans got 200 percent richer, lucky me!
I got just 32% richer.
I didn’t gain as much as he did,
but I don’t see how I’m hurt.
I’m 32 percent richer!
And yes, that’s adjusting for inflation.
and it doesn’t even count
all the cool new stuff innovation gave me.
And here’s another misleading claim:
The lack of economic mobility
Watching the news,
you’d think people born poor in America
have little chance to become rich.
A striking lack of economic mobility in America.
It’s true that people with rich parents
have a big advantage,
but it’s not like Americans are locked in.
Economists at Harvard and Berkeley
crunched the numbers and found most people born to
the richest fifth of Americans
fell out of that bracket within 20 years.
Likewise, most born to the poorest fifth
climbed to a higher quintile.
Some make it all the way to the top.
One study looking at that top bracket found
Three out of four Americans will hit that
top 20% at some point in their lifetime.
Three out of four people?
Yes.
There is the opportunity to have that mobility
and to make an amazing income in this country.
You see that if you just look at the billionaires
on the Forbes richest list.
Most are self-made.
In other words, they didn’t inherit the money,
they created their own fortunes.
But politicians and the media say that inequality
itself is a huge problem.
Frustrations over income inequality
There’s an inequality in this country right now
that is threatening to tear us apart.
It might tear us apart,
if people come to believe that all inequality is evil.
but why is that true?
Progressives like to point out that
Scandinavian countries have much more equal incomes
than America does
[Afghanistan]
But incomes are more equal in Afghanistan too.
Incomes tend to be equal when everyone is poor.
Total equality isn’t possible.
[Adele singing]
Some people are just better singers than others.
The best performer in the country
The best athletes are just physically different.
[gymnastics cheering]
There's inequality in everything.
There's inequality in free time.
There's inequality in parents.
I don't have any parents or grandparents.
We’re are all so different in so many ways.
I have two kidneys.
There are people out there who need one,
don't have one that functions.
Should the government be able to take my kidney
because somebody else needs it?
How is it not wrong that some people have
so much more than others?
What's wrong about that?
It's absolutely right.
It's unfair.
Life is unfair.
Unfair is good.
Unfair is a feature.
It's not a bug.
Something to think about next time someone
tells you that it's government’s job
to make everyone equal.